basem édition de musique est encore
l'invité exceptionnel
oui ça peut tirer donc une chance
exceptionnelle nous accueillons de
martine monteil qui est donc la première
femme patron du 36 quai des orfèvres qui
a fait une carrière exemplaire dans la
famille donc c'est une chance que je
remercie énormément de de nous rejoindre
aujourd'hui je vous propose de rejoindre
l'estrade
bonjour à tous et merci de m'accueillir
une personnalité un petit peu atypique
parmi toutes ces éminentes personnalités
du monde de l'industrie l'économie etc
je suis très impressionné un peu moins
que nous je pense
est-ce que sur certains sujets en tout
cas une carrière brillante exceptionnel
donc j'ai eu la chance d'échanger avec
vous téléphone et en plus j'ai trouvé
dans une dimension très humaine
donc là je peux je propose c'est que
nous découvrions cette carrière qui est
extrêmement difficile à résumer en si
peu de temps
martine monteil a accepté de le faire
sur des thèmes clés
donc pour ceux qui voudront poursuivre
l'expérience
il existe des livres et il a été même
tiré un film est exact de votre côté des
films dont qui se dénoue mais c'était
flic tout simplement le producteur a
repris le titre de mon livre
c'était d'ailleurs c'était sur fond
d'affaires guy georges mais c'est pas
l'affairé guy georges là qui primait il
a voulu montrer un peu ce qu'était un
rôle de femme les fins des difficultés
au contraire peut-être certaines
facilités en tout cas le côté justement
la part humaine aussi de notre métier au
travers de cette affaire si difficile
alors votre histoire donc lié à la
police démarre par une question
familiale si j'ai bien noté
oui c'est ça c'est à dire que je suis
enfin mon grand père était déjà
policiers mon père aussi
évidemment c'est surtout l' influence de
mon père qui a été déterminant mais par
un aspect bien sûr que finalement j'ai
tout petit j'ai comment dire gg grimper
les escaliers du quai des orfèvres bon
mais je me rendais pas compte
enfin je trouvais assez extraordinaire
j'allais voir papa et ses copains parce
que les collègues pour moi c'était des
copains dans la mesure où ma mère ne
travaillait pas comme beaucoup des
épouses de policiers à l'époque elle
vais plutôt leurs enfants avec des vie
de patachon de leur marine c'est à dire
beaucoup beaucoup à l'extérieur ce qui
fait que très peu des pousses travailler
et ma mère ne travaillons pas très
souvent faisait venir les équipes
puisqu'il était à l'antigang je ne
voulais pas dis donc à la à ce qu'on
appelle la brigade de recherche et
d'intervention antigang donc alors
c'était un métier très très difficile et
là ce que j'ai pu remarquer surtout
c'est que c'étaient des hommes qui
étaient heureux série partait au travail
dans des conditions difficiles c'est
très froid c'était la nuit et où j'étais
très heureux on n'entendait jamais une
critique négative
il y avait il pas de jalousie il y avait
une confraternité exceptionnel à tout ça
c'est peut-être à mon corps défendant
est entré comme ça en moi et ce qui fait
que quand j'ai fait des études de droit
de l'institut de criminologie aussi
quand même c'est quelque chose qui
m'attirait beaucoup je fais court parce
que j'essaye de survoler ma carrière
parce que ce que je dis souvent c'est
que je pourrais en parler en 30 minutes
ou en trois heures
mais voilà donc j'essaye d'adapter mon
discours autant qu'ils mettent à partit
donc ça n'est pas toujours toujours
facile en tout cas si vous voulez ses
études m'ont confortée sentait bien que
alors on dirait
j'aurais pu être avocat jean-pierre
magistrat bah non c'est quand même
policier qui l'intéressait c'est le côté
chasseurs et cette traque cette étude
sinon les en première ligne les voyous
le magistrat il les a c'est prémâché
tout a été fait à ilo reste qu'à les
mettre en prison bon ça si seulement ils
pouvaient le faire plus souvent
donc alors voilà martine vous avez temps
en temps je me lâche impoli mais
j'espère c'est ça fait partie du jeu
vous avez été pionnière alors parce que
la vie alors effectivement on vous
remercie de faire cet exercice en peu de
temps par c'est une carrière
exceptionnelle par contre vous avez été
en plus pionnière voilà c'est vrai que
quand il s'est agi de choisir donc voilà
il ya eu un premier concours que j'ai
raté mon m'a dit avec quatre places donc
de peu mais je les rater donc soyons
fair-play donc quatre collègues ont
choisi d'ailleurs deux ont choisi les
renseignements généraux et de la
direction de la surveillance du
territoire
c'était quand même assez extraordinaire
parce qu'on voit déjà qu'elle s'était
mise dans des services de renseignement
voyez c'est à dire un petit peu quand
même à la bruit à l'abri c'est ces voix
là on n'est pas très con n'est pas connu
d'ailleurs en dehors de l'annonce dans
les journaux du fait qu'il y avait des
commissaires de police dans la police
nationale
on n'a plus entendu parler des loyers
c'était un choix je ne me moque pas là
c'est un choix vous allez dans ces
directions c'est sûr et puis la deuxième
promotion donc voilà je j'entre à saint
cyr au mont d'or et nous sommes huit sur
donc ça reste il d'entrée mais enfin à
doubler quand même l'effectif féminin du
point de vue des commissaires c'est déjà
pas si mal
voilà et donc moi je suis entré dans
cette fonction mais par contre alors je
sais où je dois aller c'est la police
judiciaire et nulle part ailleurs
ça veut pas dire que les autres
directions sont moins bonnes
très belle direction chacun il fait un
métier assez extraordinaire assez
difficile aussi et je dirais que c'est
l'ensemble de tous ces métiers qui
donnent la police nationale parce que
quelquefois nous nous croisons tous sur
une même mission
je parle du terrorisme ou de très
grandes affaires là il faut que je sois
voilà travailler en commun donc voilà on
se retrouve là donc je prends la pj à
l'amphi garnison donc ces deux ans de
formation un an d'école à saint cyr au
mont d'or près de lyon et un ans à
l'époque où c'était ça c'était neuf 9
mois d'école et un an de formation j'ai
fait ma formation à la préfecture de
police de paris où je reviendrai donc je
choisi paris et la police judiciaire et
je suis nommé d'abord dans une petite
petite non c'est la moyenne délinquance
dans une brigade territoriale
aujourd'hui on dirait indique strict de
police c'est à dire un service où il ya
kiki qui est compétent sur quatre
arrondissements
voyez à peu près donc moyenne
délinquance c'est à dire que dans
l'organisation parisienne vous avez les
commissariats vous aviez à l'époque
toutes les brigades territoriales
district aujourd'hui est ensuite les
brigades centrales mais les juges
schématise mais pour rendre les choses
plus simples les brigades centrales donc
au quai des orfèvres
bon c'est des brigades fort potentiel
dans des catégories différentes
vous avez les stups l'abri à la fameuse
brigade criminelle les mineurs le band
le grand banditisme
voilà vous avez donc des spécificités
est suffisamment armé pour faire face à
des grosses affaires à des gros
événements voilà donc moi je suis
stagiaire là et c'est vrai que les
premières années donc année de stage
puis première année de fonction dont je
suis nommé à la quatrième raid
territoriale on vous accueille un peu
comme un élément encore pas tout à fait
bien identifiés voyez sauf oui bon c'est
une femme
les emmerdements commence voyez c'est
surtout pour la direction d'ailleurs
c'est c'est drôle je m'en rendrai compte
plus tard il s'est vraiment surtout pour
la direction les autres mais les les
collaborateurs bon ils sont un petit peu
attendre on va voir
est-ce qu'elle va venir avec nous est ce
qu'il y aura sept courra jusque là vous
était d'ailleurs à respecter très
rapidement oui oui mais ça après si vous
voulez je pense que c'est un petit peu
l'autorité naturelle et l'expérience
aussi au fil des années donc
ça ne se passe pas trop mal je traverse
quand même des affaires déjà un peu un
peu difficile et puis petit à petit
la direction
je dis voilà notre temps d'observation
dit tiens on va lui confier un
commissariat oui c'est à dire que le
fait de confier un commissariat en
général c'était des commissaires assez
expérimenté vous voyez capable de tenir
leur arrondissement
connaissant bien de toutes les règles
toute la procédure l'élément solide
voyez-vous du quartier alors ils se sont
dit une femme est ce que ça va passer
oui c'était toujours leurs questions
est-ce que ça va passer alors là c'était
pas temps encore pour les collaborateurs
puisqu'il avait déjà testé un peu il n'y
a pas eu la révolution bon mais est-ce
que les administrés vont accepter une
femme dans le commissariat
alors pour pas prendre de risque ils
m'ont collé dans le 7e arrondissement
ont choisi le plus petit quoi pas tout à
fait le plus petit c'était celui du 2ème
arrondissement c'était le my mais comme
il venait de nommer quelqu'un ils m'ont
mis à saint thomas d'aquin donc que des
commissariats qui venait de se libérer
ailleurs dix ans on prend pas de risques
dans le 7ème il se passe pratiquement
rien grave erreur
créharer parce que là bas vous avez
justement quand même une
bourgeoisie aisée et c'est assez
exigeante tout donc de dire tout n'était
pas facile il fallait prendre des gants
il fallait bien surveiller son personnel
parce que pour éviter qu'il y ait un
petit peu des problèmes donc une
certaine délicatesse à la limite
quelqu'un de plus expérimenté c'est pas
plus mal
l'iman choisi ça c'est finalement très
très bien passé
j'avais gainsbourg j'avais le luron qui
venait régulièrement me filer son permis
de conduire
madame le commissaire on me la retire
étonné je vous le donne ma rolls
m'attend vous le savez ne vous inquiétez
pas toujours beaucoup d'humour 20 bon
voilà c'était j'étais pas mal quoi je
veux dire 20 tessin pas bon quand on
découvrait un portefeuille c'était le
portefeuille d'un ministre fallait faire
très attention pouvait y avoir des
photos de danse est arrivé donc d'où
vous voyez comme quoi j'ai j'ai pu
démontrer que j'étais extrêmement
délicat discrète et caetera et je me
retrouve à matignon avec le portefeuille
que j'avais conservé que je suis à
l'épée restituée voyez vous donc voilà
tout ça pour dire que c'est délicat ça
se passe bien mais hélas pour eux
j'attends un enfant je suis bien obligé
de l'annoncé pitch façon ça va se voir
donc je leur dis est là c'est la
catastrophe voyez pour ça que j'en ai
parfait un second parce que ça posait
problème à elle va s'absenter c'est ça
le problème avec les bonnes femmes etc
etc
enfin bon pour moi je faisais mon boulot
je m'occupais pas de tout ce qui se
disait d'ailleurs souvent on me le
disait pas en face est pas forcément un
grand courage mais je veux qu'on me
rapporte est bien sûr donc j'ai
poursuivi mon chemin j'ai continué à
grossir
c'est là que je raconte est là je me
retrouvais dans des scènes avec des
cadavres en putréfaction et en pleine
nuit et où personne se soucier de la
petite commissaire enceinte voyez-vous
c'était pas pour ma personne j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir une bonne santé
j'ai supporté tout ça enfin ce qui me
sont venus en aide c'est le brigadier
qui me voient enfilé des gants il ya
patronne vous n'allez pas toucher à ce
corps vous avez vu dans quel état il est
je dis oui d'accord enfin elle allongée
là mais si un couteau en dessous on fait
quoi
c'est plus une enquête décès ah oui oui
bon alors il m'aide c'est un inspecteur
que j'avais dans mon service quand il a
vu et je m'en suis mordu
tout d'un coup il me dit qu'on avait une
voiture quand on est en permanence de
nuit et dc si vous voulez je vais
prendre la voiture j'ai pourquoi vous
voulez prendre la voiture jaune a besoin
si je suis appelé la nuit il faut bien
je me déplace
non mais je viendrai vous chercher je
vous accompagne vous voyez est en fait
sa femme son épouse était enceinte en
même temps que moi mais je sais qu'ils
veulent a dit bien après voyez c'est à
dire que lui il avait eu le réflexe il a
un peu transposés et il a dit voyez donc
c'est venu des gens de la base ou de
deux parmi nos collaborateurs quand je
dis ça y'a rien de péjoratif pas du tout
de la direction faisait des nuits garde
à vue de 20h à 6h du matin personnes se
demandaient si tout allait bien
personne voyez bon à l'époque et pas de
psychologues et tout ça bon vaty drame
n'avait pas besoin de toute façon
j'aurais décliné parce que moi ça ne m'a
pas tellement perturbé pas tellement
temps en temps je me disais mon dieu si
sombre un gars quoi voilà c'est tout ce
que j'ai du haut de ma jeunesse quoi 7
mai mais dire que j'ai été perturbée non
pis là on va dire mais j'ai été bien
venger parce que le plus mauvais de tous
il a eu un infarctus mais sévère mais
sévère il est resté mais bien plus
longtemps que qu'une maternité hors-jeu
quoi vraiment là c'est ce que j'ai dit
je les remarques et j ai quand même là
le directeur adjoint il s'absente
vraiment longtemps ainsi martin ça vous
a pas empêché de sanaa pente de d'avancé
et j'ai avancé franchir de très belles
autre étape
voilà alors donc j'étais en commissariat
finalement ça s'est très bien passé et
moi j'adorais le contact avec le public
donc les gens me le rendaient bien donc
si vous les gg ça s'est passé dans une
très bonne ambiance si je puis dire qui
je peux parler comme ça s'agissant d'un
commissariat mais j'aimais aller
j'aime rendre service j'aime venir en
aide on était là au service de nos
concitoyens
on m'a fort on m'a confié un
commissariat plus importante dans le 12e
arrondissement là pour le coup très
populaire etc
donc c'est vrai que c'était beaucoup
plus animée mais je me suis plus aussi
vous vous adaptez à la population et et
franchement c'est on peut faire en plus
de belles petites affaires parce qu'il
ya des choses à faire
donc ça s'est très bien passé ensuite un
jour parce que finalement vous décidez
pas vous en vous appelle le directeur
vous appelle et vous dis voilà j'ai
pensé
à vous pour un poste qui se libère à la
brigade des stupéfiants et là il vous
dit voilà je vais vous y nommer alors
comme le numéro 3 1 et pas voilà bien
sûr normal les jeunes encore et numéro
trois bombes toute façon vous en avez
pour 7 ans minimum
ah bon merci monsieur le directeur mais
on vous laisse pas trop le choix c'est
comme ça mais c'est pareil il veut dire
moi les règles ne me ça ne me dérangeait
pas voilà j'ai eu et j'ai compris la
démarche parce que les stups faut déjà
bien acquérir tout ce qui en fin la
matière la matière les réseaux tout ça
c'est ça c'est pas du premier jour où on
se dit bon oeil à ce qu'on voit à la
télé est d'accord mais quand même
cc il faut bien comprendre il faut
connaître les produits et tous parce
qu'on fait une formation en même temps
il faut être apte à faire une formation
d'abord d' des collaborateurs qui
arrivent mais aussi éventuellement on
est sollicité pour faire des
collaborations et ça c'est quelque chose
que j'ai beaucoup développée vers
l'extérieur c'est à dire lâche une
petite digression mais c'est vrai ça a
beaucoup marché vers les lycées vers les
écoles d'infirmières vais enfin tous
ceux qui souhaitaient que l'on leur
explique un peu ce que c'était bien
pouvait nous et on y aller ça s'est
tellement bien marché qu'après on a pris
un autre commissaire en d'ailleurs pour
pouvoir aussi venir m'aider dans cette
tâche parce qu'en même temps on arrêtait
des voyous parce que c'est quand même ça
la police c'est pour ça que j'étais
entré dans la police la chasse et ça ça
me plaisait beaucoup
donc on stupide je me suis régalé on a
fait très très belle affaire c'est là où
on a commencé à avoir des articles dans
la presse
puisque quand on réussissait une belle
affaire à l'époque 10 kilos d'héroïne
vous aviez la une des journaux quoi bon
10 kilos d'héroïne bon là aujourd'hui je
suis pas si un autre fils pas sûr bon
c'est l'évolution de notre société c'est
comme ça donc à l'époque voilà vous avez
aussi des articles quand c'est une
célébrité quand il s'agit d'un écrivain
oui alors vous faites allusion fait ben
oui en suivait un jour un dealer mais de
cocaïne l'un de cocaïne qui qui
distribue ce qu'ils distribuaient il
avait des adresses dans paris certains
nombres et il s'arrête entre autres
entre autres une adresse rue du cherche
midi
et donc nous on le suit à suivre après
évidemment on essaye de voir qui il a
livré et rue du cherche midi il avait
livré françoise sagan alors le problème
c'est que une fois que vous interpellé
que votre affaire et les murs elle est
prête là encore j'ai pas faut faire des
développements là dessus mais disons que
voilà tout est mûr vous allez intervenir
il faut avoir justement tous les
acheteurs parce qu'ils sont en quelque
sorte les témoins de la livraison du
dealer donc voilà il peut pas dire c'est
que l'autre on prend alors il a fallu
aller chercher françoise sagan en
général quand il ya des personnalités
puisque là on éclate est tout le monde
moi je suis allé à cette adresse parce
que très souvent il ya des il y en a qui
au contraire justement là le luron qui
prennent tout de façon
sympathique gentil même dans les
affaires économiques et financières vous
avez des gens qui voient là il joue le
jeu bon il faut qu'ils viennent ils sont
éventuellement même placé en garde à vue
il n'ya pas d'esclandre la seule chose
qui vous demande c'est la discrétion
pour arriver au quai des orfèvres moi ça
je folle octroyé ça c'est normal mais
sinon ils sont bien mais plus vous en
avez d'autres c'est le scandale et c'est
souvent le cas c'est à dire oui vous
vous permettez je vais en parler à etc
etc et sagan ça risquait d'être un petit
peu ça quand même elles avaient des
relations haut placées
alors donc j'y suis allé et ça s'est
très mal passé bien évidemment parce
qu'en fait pas par elle en définitive
parce que quand même finalement assez
intelligente mais la furie qui lui
servait de secrétaire de secrétaire et
elle elle j'ai cru qu'elles allaient me
tuer j'ai cru qu'elles allaient me tuer
me saute dessus dont j'étais pas
seulement on l'a calmé un la grande
fille on l'a laissée de côté
et puis moi j'ai parlé à madame sagan et
puis voilà je lui ai demandé d'être
raisonnable et puis je dis voilà il ya
deux solutions vous êtes madame sagan
c'est un fait mais moi voilà je suis là
et on est en affaires vous avez été
livrés il ne dit pas non c'est pas la
peine on a tout vu tout est photographié
tout est acté alors le plus simple ou
vous résistez vous continuez à me dire
que non ferreux et ont fait une
perquisition je ne suis pas intimidé la
perquisition elle aura lieu
je fouille tout et je trouve
l'enveloppent de la drogue ou alors on
vous est intelligente et vous dites y'a
un faisan cours et évitons cela c'est ce
qui s'est passé mais s'est montrée
intelligente je suis parti avec elle
dans sa bibliothèque elle avait des faux
livres ça fait une belle plante et donc
elle m'a donné la drogue et ce qui s'est
passé
et c'est là où ça a été déplorable c'est
que je l' ai entendu personnellement
d'ailleurs au quai des orfèvres donc
assez longuement est d'ailleurs un
moment donné elle faisait du
prosélytisme
j'ai dit est ce que vous vous rendez
compte vous me dites ça à moi c'est mais
c'est extraordinaire et vous c'est
toujours comme ça vous vous exprimez
toujours de cette façon à faire du
prosélytisme ce que vous ayez envie de
vous défoncer nous sommes dérange pas
mais que vous essayez de de convaincre
que c'est bon c'est un petit peu dommage
quand même surtout que j'avais envie de
lui dire parce que commençait déjà quand
même un sens qu'elle avait du vécu alors
bon voilà ça se passe bien quand même
l'audition
et puis j'ai même la courtoisie c'était
normal d'ailleurs de la faire
raccompagner en voiture au milieu de la
nuit
et puis surlendemain elle hurle au
téléphone et demande à oui vous m'avez
trail ou parce qu'elle m'avait dit
surtout vous ne dirai rien je veux pas
que ça se sache touché mais madame moi
je fais une affaire je sais que vous
êtes un témoin dans une affaire il ya
aucune raison je vais pas demain posté
le procès verbal pour dire tiens voilà
on a eu cinq ans pas du tout faute
d'abord à vous êtes vous n'êtes qu'un
témoin vous êtes quelqu'un qui qui qui
se drogue
vous n'êtes pas le dealer c'est pas vous
bref est en fait le ce fameux
surlendemain on a la haine du canal à la
une du canard enchaîné quelques il ya
quelques feuillets quelque chose quelque
chose là il ya quelque chose et donc est
la une du canard enchaîné bonjour cas
mais c'est dur
alors évidemment elle a cru que c'était
nous lagueux l'aimé il était urgent et a
coûté calmez vous je vous jure que c'est
pas nous je n'ai pas à me justifier
maintenant c'est pas nous seulement moi
en attendant avec cette histoire
on a été convoqué à l'hygiène la police
des polices avait trois heures ils m'ont
gardé les petits collègues pour essayer
de me faire cracher que c'était nous
mais ce n'était pas nous quand même bon
on est flic pas pour rien j'ai dit aux
gars il faut absolument savoir d'où ça
vient parce que eux j'étais sur deux
j'étais sur mes hommes j'ai dit non ça
c'est pas à eux causé aucun intérêt
d'ailleurs ça nous a pas ému cinq ans
passe à gand il s'en foutait
complètement et donc et on a regardé la
foule la faune fin la une du canard et
on a vu qu'il y avait une petite petits
défauts sur le procès verbal
alors je dis tiens le will lpv initial
on seul même les mêmes les copies on a
regardé il n'y avait pas ce petit défaut
alors bon j'étais intéressant quand même
dit à eux et c'était un défaut de qui
tenait à une machine à photocopier fait
on a fait une morale enquête
on a été un peu léger est ce parce que
je sais pas trop fort là dessus donc et
on a pu démontrer que ça venait du
palais de justice
voilà donc ce n'était pas nous à nous
avons été réhabilité auprès de madame
sagan c'est vrai que ça bien souvent des
avocats même quelquefois de certains
magistrats ça s'est vu enfin souvent des
avocats sont bien trop content de
balancer le truc ça ça fait le buzz
comme on dirait aujourd'hui quoi
voilà pour madame cinq ans c'était en
tout cas ça illustre également les liens
entre les médias justement la justice et
donc si nous poursuivons parce que oui
si vous tenez à très cadré monsieur je
sais vous avez le timing alors assis
dans la boue donc du coup si nous
franchissons les étapes dans le temps
donc on vous nomme à nouveau donc en
progression voilà ce progresser au moc
office et la première fois lors à chaque
fois ça a été la première fois donc à
chaque fois j'ai fait un peu de dunes
médiatique mais l'administration étaient
très complices si vous voulez parce qu'
il fallait montrer aux jeunes femmes que
oui voilà la police s'ouvrait aux femmes
et qu'il fallait pas hésiter à passer
les concours etc
c'était quoi voilà quand un certain donc
là on me propose la brigade de
répression du proxénétisme bon pourquoi
pas donc cette fois ci je suis chef
fini le plus l'adjoint je suis chef est
donc évidemment c'est un milieu très
particulier les prostituées
les proxénètes les boîtes de nuit aussi
parce que on contrôler l'ensemble des
établissements de nuit de la capitale
donc c'est ça aussi c'est comme un
aspect intéressant et en même temps qui
donne qui donne du travail et à l'époque
si vous voulez très rapidement j'ai eu
une chose c'était envahissement de la
rue saint-denis par des ghanéenne mais
alors un niveau ça incroyable de
l'abattage de l'abattage c'était plus
les les prostituées qu'on voit dans les
films d'une certaine époque
voyez la fille adossé au mur la
cigarette au bec et ces noms là
c'étaient des filles qu'on voyait un peu
dans la rue mais qui quelquefois ne
bougeait pas de la pièce où elle était
cantonnée sert une chambre des fois
divisée en deux points 4 selon la pièce
et et voilà l abattage quoi alors
c'était eux mêmes sur le plan humain
sanitaires et tous étaient extrêmement
grave
donc il ya eu çà c'est à dire en très
fin dans ses réseaux c'est à dire les
arrêter faire cesser ça on a beaucoup
oeuvré effectivement on a fermé ses
studios
inutile de vous dire que après il
fallait réhabiliter les immeubles c'est
ce qui s'est fait petit à petit mais ça
c'est fait et puis dans cette brigade de
répression du proxénétisme dont vous
aviez tout ce qui était la prostitution
de rue et en studio ce qu'on appelle le
proxénétisme immobilier et vous avez
aussi ce qu'on appelle la galanterie la
galanterie c'est à dire c'est les
réseaux clandestins du type de madame
claude
voilà alors on en a fait pas mal des
filles d'ailleurs de toutes origines
même des asiatiques avec tous et un jour
j'ai mon chef de groupe qui vient me
voir et qui me dit madame
lui c'est un 13 ans très ancien il me
dit il avait beaucoup de l'informateur
il me dit je crois que la maire claude
elle a repris du service
j -ab ont alors vu j'ai me dit dont elle
doit pas être jeune chaude cette dame à
bali non mais je vous dis que je pense
que c'était géninfo je l'écouté en faut
pas se contenter d'une info parce
qu'évidemment c'était un petit peu
sensible alors agir il faut savoir déjà
est ce que c'est c'est fonder est-ce que
donc on a un mini-clip des écoutes des
surveillances et c'est effectivement
madame claude qui s'appelait de son vrai
nom ferment de grue dès avait repris du
service sous un autre nom d'ailleurs et
voilà elle avait déjà
on a évalué à peu près de 13 à 15 filles
quoi qui tournait pour elle à peu près
de la même façon que du temps de sa
splendeur
alors sa splendeur c'était dans les
années cinquante à soixante dix on va
dire 75 et où elle avait un immense
réseau fait de très près jolie fille et
même d'anciennes actrices l'ancien
mannequin de chanteuse tout ça bon enfin
il est certaines sont encore vivantes
d'autres sont décédés mais enfin bon
elle avait vraiment le gratin de ces
jeunes femmes il faut dire que l étaient
éduqués ils devaient savoir souvent
parler anglais bien se tenir
et elle était une garantie de bonne
santé aussi ce qui était quand même très
important pour le client d'être sûr
d'avoir mendy pas une prostituée ondine
galante de qualité voilà donc elle était
très exigeante sur la marchandise
parce que l cette aide de la marchandise
ses fils a hélas ce qu'était le comique
si je puis dire de l'histoire c'est
qu'en fait elle était complice d'un
chirurgien esthétique ça ce qu'on ne
savait pas nous sommes là découvert au
cours de surveillance c'est que elle
faisait venir les filles qu'elles
s'éteignent matignon dont quelques uns
ils repéraient est là faisait venir donc
se déshabiller voir un peu comment était
la fille et tout est lui trouvait
toujours un défaut toujours un défaut
est d'ailleurs le jour 2 comme ça elle
livrait la fille à un chirurgien
esthétique qui était complice donc est
la fille était ferré et en plus
financièrement surtout parce qu'il
faisait faire une opération d'un certain
coût après pour payer ben si tu veux
payer tiens voilà j'ai un client ce soir
si tu veux c'est la moitié de ton
intervention - ça a commencé comme ça et
après ben voilà la fille et quand on l'a
interpellé le jour j les les
collaborateurs était avec un jeune
commissaire vie sert qu'à partir du
moment où vous quand même devenu chef de
service bien moins drôle
vous pouvez pas aller vous même tout le
temps sur le terrain faux délégués
vous vous êtes le patron vous avez un
rôle tenu du service et là j'avais
envoyé mon adjoint un autre commissaire
alors ils avaient là l'oreille à la
porte et il l'entendait dire à la fille
vont toutes façons toi pour faire ta la
culotte de cheval il faut absolument
refaire ça ça passera pas je te refais
faire ça mais t'inquiètes pas j'ai une
adresse des rameaux est en fait la fille
on l'a sauvé de l'intervention
esthétique puisque on a déboulé et qu'on
a ramassé tout le monde y compris madame
claude qui n'était pas contente du tout
je vous le donne en mille
la jeune femme qui est qui et est entre
ses mains à ce moment là qu'elle avait
trouvé avec la queue de cheval j ai un
méga giga bon à la culotte de cheval la
fiche c'est étonnant blessés
il m'a dit regarde et la fille passe
elle allait pour être auditionné dans un
bureau sur un jean sur la peau voyez
tout elle sortait du crazy horse
c'est une ancienne danseuse du crazy
horse qui était en quelque sorte entre
guillemets retraités voyez vous et quels
sans doute l'habitude d'un certain train
de vie qui s'est dit au fond tient
peut-être pendant une certaine période
doit envoyer la culotte de cheval vont
donc c'était vraiment une peau de vache
une vraie peau de vache elle est arrivée
comme une furie est là c'est un scandale
et c'est sauf que vont où l'un n'est pas
faire bouger le présent de la république
définissant son temps elle avait été
condamnée que fiscalement cette femme
jamais pénalement
c'était la première fois donc elle ne
digérait pas voilà donc madame claude
elle a été un voilage estimé faisons un
saut dans le temps
vous avez encore votre carrière dans les
événements marquants des événements qui
n'arrive quasiment jamais surtout en
france je parle de l'arrestation de
serial-killer comme on dit maintenant
donc là j'ai justement 1 alors ça c'est
encore un peu plus tard c'est pas royal
ça mais là ça a commencé donc dans le
xiième adoré arrondissement quand c'est
non c'est ça mais en fait je vous ai
laissé faire le flou et donc on a sauté
sur certaines vous avez fait une
première affaire ses dettes l'étrangleur
du 12e voilà alors ça j'étais stagiaire
en fait c'est au tout début mais comme
je j'accélère un peu si vous voulez bon
je passe sur certains trucs mais là dans
la thématique effectivement cyrielle
killer c'est très rare pour un
commissaire de police pour un policier
en général peu importe le grade
d'ailleurs c'est de rencontrer dans sa
vie professionnelle 3 cyrielle killer ça
mais ça c'est pas vous qui choisissez je
veux dire c'est les hasards de la vie de
la profession etc et je suis stagiaire
et dans la 3e brigade territoriale dans
laquelle je me trouve en stage il ya une
fille qui est assassinée dans un parking
et elle est étranglée dans sa voiture on
trouve juste une fourchette à côté
d'elle et à rien alors comme moi
évidemment j'avais pensé jeune
commissaire encore stagiaire c'était
formidable parce que je faisais des
voleurs des escrocs enfin tout un tas de
trucs mais là il y avait enfin une année
à une affaire criminelle donc c'était
formidable
on se dit au patron je peux y aller dit
mais bien sûr au contraire vas-y etc
bon voilà donc j'y suis allé avec les
légats donc c'était déjà très poignant
quoi surtout la rencontre avec les
parents enfin vous voyez tout tout tout
ce qui concerne les enveloppes une
affaire criminelle est grave et peu de
temps après nous on commence à
travailler on comprend quand même que ça
une connotation sexuelle je suis vite je
vais quand même pour pouvoir parler tout
est donc connotation sexuelle donc moi
je avec le capitaine qu'on avait mis à
ma disposition inspecteur principal à
l'époque on dit tiens on va faire tous
les fichiers
d'affaires à connotation sexuelle
histoire de voir s'il ya dit quelque
chose qui peuvent correspondre pour
qu'on se met à travailler bien bien sûr
ces affaires et puis tout d'un coup
deuxième affaire met ses pin troisième
la troisième c'est une tentative
voilà la troisième est une tentative est
toujours avec le même le même modus
operandi si vous voulez puis une autre à
la finale alors on est venu ici je
remonte un petit peu dans le temps dès
la deuxième c'était la psychose à paris
c'est à dire que vous aviez tous les
journaux qui faisait une lune avec
l'étrangleur départ qui n'est plus une
femme qui garde une voiture dans un
parking plus c'est incroyable ce qui
fait que le préfet de police à l'époque
a donné pour instruction de faire dd des
descentes de police enfin dans les
parkings des rondes etc et même à
suggérer qu'on mette des chèvres a tout
de suite compris les femmes dans la
police il y en avait quelques unes aux
mineurs et puis il y avait voilà des
gens comme moi un petit peu moins de 18
filles qui existaient à l'époque d'un
police on les a mis dans des petits
groupes et on est descendu dans les
parkings du 10e arrondissement
je peux vous dire qu'à l'époque il n'y
avait pas de radio et pas de téléphone y
avait en avait rien on avait l'alpha pas
je voyais un peu
vous avez largement le temps de vous
faire violer ça c'est sûr voire plus
donc c'était alors on avait un sifflet
quand même on avait un sifflet puis on
savait que les gars étaient était
derrière et bon ses ballets dont moi
aussi je me suis baladée dans les
parkings bien noir là whaou
c'est pas extraordinaire dit on sait
jamais je peux quand même le rencontrer
et ça peut tomber sur moi aussi bref
c'est pas par ces opérations qu'on a
réussi à l'attraper
on l'a rattrapé par le fait que la
dernière personne c'était une yougoslave
elle avait un contact avec lui on a
trouvé dans ces que c'était un contact
donc on a travaillé sur cet homme et en
travaillant sur cet homme et en
l'identifiant on se rend compte qu'elle
avait fait de la prison en yougoslavie
pour des affaires à connotation sexuelle
ça devenait intéressant et on est allé
il habiter chez sa mère on est allés
chez sa mère et en perquisition chez sa
mère on trouve la même fourchette
sauf que comme dirait monsieur juppé
c'était une fourchette de prisunic et
l'avocat n'importe quel avocat la
fourchette de prisunic et ben oui à une
fourchette et alors il a plein des
fourchettes comme ça vous allez chez
n'importe qui pour une fourchette comme
ça ça tient on avait à rien à rien rien
sur le pont l'adn n'existait pas
empreintes digitales rien du tout dans
l'est sur les scènes de crime rien a
relevé à l'époque voilà on était dans le
bleu quoi complet et notre homme est
arrêté
finalement quand même parce que son
historique nous parle
il est ramené à la brigade territoriale
hélas les inspecteurs s'étaient des
inspecteurs dia plus d'une trentaine
d'années voyez vous fasse un yougoslave
puis sans un regard noir très sombre
très déterminés ils avaient mangé des
morceaux de ferraille en prison pour
pouvoir aller à l'infirmerie et
s'échappe et enfin une tête brûlée et
donc ils ont parlé virilement je n'étais
pas dedans mais
j'entendais donc c'était une autre
époque
lui s'en foutait parce qu'ils avaient
décidé qu'il parlerait pas donc ils
l'ont fatigué un peu ils sont partis
déjeuner et moi je suis resté avec mon
inspecteur les je lui dis si on lui
donnait à boire un sandwich et qu'on
parle et je fais court il vient me le
regard toujours aussi but et puis je me
suis dit en plus moi une femme jeune de
surcroît dans mon bref et je prends sa
fouille en même temps qu'ils mangent
quand même son sandwich et puis je vois
dans la fouille une photo d'un petit
garçon de deux ans alors je sors la
photo et je lui montrais j'ai dit c'est
city lui c'est ton fils et là il me
regarde
enfin il me regarde et me dit oui j'ai
dit alors didon c'est dommage parce que
là tu vas le revoir il va avoir 25 ans
ce sera un homme il te reconnaîtra pas
ça c'est sûr c'est je commence à
discuter avec lui tout mais j'adorais
cette espèce de joutes psychologique
entre un type qui joue sa vie sur le
plan pénal et puis l'intérêt que nous
avions nous qui n'avions aucune preuve a
essayé de d'avoir des aveux est bon il
s'est pas laissé faire tout de suite
beaucoup discuté gg on se fait mal on
discute ans j'ai même été jusqu'à dire
que certainement ses filles qui étaient
assez jolie et ses victimes
elle avait un peu provoqué voyez-vous et
c'est bon c'est dur quand vous
connaissez les victimes leurs familles
et tous mais bon c'est le jeu vous en
faites vous voulez arriver à quelque
chose parce que vous vous doutez vous
avez l'instinct que c'est lui mais il
faut pas se contenter d'un instinct il
faut avoir des certitudes il faut avoir
des preuves alors là entre le l'aveu
autres quand vous n'avez rien d'autre
c'est maintenant aujourd'hui ça peut
être plus confortable lundi georges par
exemple adn du sang des mégots on a tout
ce qu'il faut quoi là à rien alors ce
qu'il faut ce sont les finit par avouer
il craque il avoue est là
le gars qui était à côté de moi il a
tout de suite dans c'était la machine à
écrire c'était pas l'ordinateur on ça
faisait du bruit ça tapait vous savez
bien tant pis il tape à la machine et
loga me parle il me pas à moi et je me
suis dit bon ça va être difficile
d'avoir du détail on est dans une
affaire de viol et ses terrains et bien
contrairement à john pas imaginer tout
il est entré dans le détail
c'était formidable de ce point de vue là
c'est à dire qu'on a eu des aveux
parfaitement circonstancié
voilà le premier le second c'est lui
mamadou traoré il nous a agressé six
femmes de la même façon
deux en sont mortes et deux autres très
gravement blessé on pensait nous qu'ils
agissaient avec une batte de base-ball
pas vrai ils agissaient avec son poing
et on l'a su plus tard et donc la presse
après la baptiser le tueur aux poings
nus on n'aurait pas imaginé parce que
les les visages des victimes étaient
fracassées et il y en a même une dans un
parking du 12e arrondissement
la fille elle a été laissée pour morte
dans un prêt d'un local à poubelles quoi
et son liquide céphalo rachidien s'est
coulé pendant au moins 2 3 heures
jusqu'à ce qu'une personne passe
et trouve alors coup de pot parce que
c'était vraiment un réduit qui était pas
un réduit de passage et là il récupère
enfin la fille on appelle la police etc
bon ben voilà et donc cette femme elle
est restée un mois et demi dans le coma
ensuite je suis allé la voir alors au
départ c'était une jolie jeune femme
blonde beau visage
elle était la chef de cabinet de jean
claude gaudin ça c'est le fait du hasard
et elle était mariée d'ailleurs avec un
à quelqu'un qui est notre collègue
encore aujourd'hui et est il du nord
quand elle s'est réveillée bien sûr eux
elle se souvenait de rien à la pauvre
femme
et s'il a fallu soixante dix agrafes de
titane pour lui reconstruire le visage
inutile de vous dire que elle était
méconnaissable donc une vie fracassé
divorce tout ce qui a suivi de
nombreuses opérations chirurgicales tout
au long de sa vie pour essayer de
retrouver un visage humain dont vous
voyez c'est ça
et alors ce qui est dans cette affaire
ce qui est bizarre c'est que plus tard
tout ça c'est dans quelques mois parce
qu'on l'arrêtait rapidement lui
justement la dernière affaire c'est sur
la dernière affaire on est con parce
qu'ils agissaient dans le 2e
arrondissement le xiiie arrondissement
et tout est là neuilly neuilly on a une
dame donc 60
11 12 13 ans je me souviens plus enfin
donc une dame d'un certain âge bien
conservé et d'un certain âge et le
visage fracassé
mais on s'est regardé parce que c'était
en ce moment se trament travailler
là-dessus fumât enfin on élimine un
petit peu parce que toutes les jeunes
femmes s'étaient justement des jeunes
femmes très joli et c'est qu'ils
n'avaient rien à voir elle n'avait pas
du tout le profil et on n'était pas dans
sa zone en général c'est ces gens là
voyez c'est l étrangleur du 10e
arrondissement ce sera guy georges
l'étrangleur de le tueur de l'est
parisien etc et donc on pense quand même
à la géographie mais quand même ce
visage fracassé comme ça ça nous parle
un peu bon et on n'a rien sauf une
canette de coca cola sur un mur est bien
plus loin de l'immeuble de cette dame
et là bingo sa match c'est à dire que
sur cette canette de coca il ya un adn
il ya un adn donc on fait tourner l'adn
alors la chute
à l'époque on a pas de fichier mais on
fait comme si on en avait 1 grâce à la
complicité d'un bon docteur pascal à
nantes 1 voyez il faut faut y aller on
mettait les les
comment dirais-je nos scellés dans le
tgv voyez lui les accueillaient là bas
et il nous faisait ça c'était formidable
heureusement qu'on a eu des gens comme
ça ce que une affaire comme ça
ce qui n'a pas dit y'a pas de fichier
adn voilà bon sinon ça aurait été en une
fraction de seconde on avait l'oeuvre
mais là quand même
il a de la chance dans ses recherches y
tombe dessus rapidement sa match et le
type il est en taule donc y'a plus qu'à
aller le cueillir il était en prison
pour autre fait bien sûr donc on le
traite la toujours paraît d'abord je
n'ai ensuite pas je fini par avouer
voilà ça c'est l'histoire de mamadou
traoré dont celui-ci prend comme dit
georges c'est-à-dire réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité assortie d'une
peine de sûreté de 22 ans
et voilà lui alors lui moi j'ai pas
connu toutes ces victimes puisque il
à vrai de 1991 à 1998 date de son
arrestation et moi j'arrive à peu près
donc fin 95 des bus 96 en définitive
mais j'ai déjà vécu une affaire en tant
que deux permanences puisque j'étais à
la tête de la brigade de répression du
banditisme est de permanence un week-end
on remplace le patron de la crim quoi
parce que bon on essaie voilà et donc
j'ai une affaire à lui
donc je vivrai toutes les autres
derrière
la caractéristique c'est la violence de
la scène de crime c'est-à-dire jeunes
jolies jeunes femmes qui sont égorgés
égorgé piquer les sous vêtements
arrachés les mains dans le dos avec du
sparadrap attachés avec du sparadrap
enfin les bons et de la torture à
connotation sexuelle que vous pouvez
imaginer
elles subissent donc le pire voilà cette
affaire elle a été très très dur pour
nous toujours pareil il n'y a pas d' à
dn de toute façon on n'en relève pas
dans les premières affaires
ce n'est qu'en 94 justement ça c'est la
coïncidence dans la sphère niche comme
celle de la balle rue du faubourg
saint-antoine
sur son ventre à la fille avait du
sperme d'un évidence donc prélèvements
avec un peu de chance c'est bien le sien
celui du tueur bon voilà et on a au
moins déjà une trace adn et à partir de
là dans les différentes chez les
différentes victimes
on retrouvera du sperme ou une fois il
s'est blessé lui aussi donc il a il a
glissé d'ailleurs sur une trace de sang
la sienne c'est l'agglo coup du pied
égyptiens qui n'en était pas un mais
c'était d'une trace de glisser enfin oui
toutes les interprétations possibles
d'une enquête mais enfin on aura de
l'adn sur ccsn la caractéristique on a
fait constituer enfin j'ai demandé à
constituèrent constituer un album pour
les assises on pouvait mettre avec du
calq une photo sur l'autre et c'était
exactement les mêmes blessures et la
même position du corps exactement de la
même façon ça veut dire que c'est une
mécanique a tué et qui rituel ça c'est
aussi le syndrome du du serial killer le
yougoslave mois il m'avait raconté que
la jouissance c'était ça c'était d'être
anglais pas le reste la jouissance était
d' étrangler et lui quand il finit par
avouer
il vous raconte c'est sur pv 1 ça a été
d'ailleurs bien heureux dit aux assises
c'est à dire qu'ils y suit une femme on
importe quel homme drague une femme dit
mais elle invite à prendre un café à la
terrasse quoi si vous voulez et lui non
il a suis ici voici l rendre dans un
immeuble si elle rentre dans un immeuble
il est content il a suis hélas il dit je
sais que je vais la tuer c'est pas pour
avoir une relation sexuelle
c'est pas ça qui vous dit il dit je sais
que je vais la tuer et en fait on
comprend que c'est vraiment un instinct
morbide et uniquement il est mû par un
instinct morbide en priorité le reste
d'ailleurs
c'est pas la performance chez lui donc
vous voyez c'est peut-être là c'est
peut-être aussi ça le
ceci explique peut-être cela en tout cas
voilà le nombre de victimes que nous
avons pu avoir et y en a une qui a
échappé donc elisabeth ortega s'en est
sorti par miracle parce qu'il est à
l'éteindre lumière et elle l a ouvert la
fenêtre elle était en raid curé de cours
au rez-de-jardin quoi et hop elle est
sortie à fond en courant et la baule il
a essayé de la rattraper
elle a été tellement speed que elle
s'est retrouvée dans la rue et là il ya
du monde allait rentrer dans le premier
café venu ça lui a permis de alors on
avait un témoin vous me direz vous c'est
quand même assez exceptionnel un témoin
comme ça elle est restée un moment
puisque vont commencer à fumer une
cigarette
d'où le mégot sauf que ça devait être
une psychomotricienne psychomotricienne
dit tiens c'est l' équilibre et c est en
fait elle appelle la vue maghrébins elle
en sortait pas c'est un maghrébin et
tout on a cherché un maghrébin a déclaré
un témoin vivant vivant c'est des rondes
battu pour chercher pour voir si elle
arrête arriverait à reconnaître on lui a
présenté des tas de photos on a fait des
tas de recherche
elle ne l'a jamais reconnue et le pire
de tout c'est qu'elle a été amenée au
service et que là il lui a été présenté
et qu'elle ne l'a pas reconnu et avoir
un peu pas là on peut pas dire qu'elle
était complexe mais comme complice c'est
vraiment il y avait un vrai sujet c'est
une sorte de blocage que voyez vous il
ya quelque chose d'ailleurs s'il fallait
pas trop faim moi j'essayais de combat
était mortifié après quand elle a su
parce qu'elle s'est dit mon dieu mais
comment j'ai pu passer à côté je sais
pas c'est comme ça c'est la vie
et donc donc on ça a été une période
quand même dommage c'était dommage là
qu'on compte qu'il ait dit qu'il était
ratée et comme il n'y avait pas d'autres
éléments à l'époque c'est comme ça voilà
alors lui c'est la faire quand même je
termine par ça qui nous permettra enfin
parce que là on est rentré en guerre
avec les la politique l'administration
et tout ça il nous le fallait ce fichier
adn et malgré tout c'est c'est ce que
j'appelle moi là bien pensants ce qu'ils
disaient encore un fichier pour la
police
quelle horreur c'est du fascisme c'est
ceci c'est cela oui mais enfin plus que
nécessaire est ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui qu'on puisse contester ce
fichier la réponse est non
elle est parfaitement indispensable et
surtout si on est victime quoi bon il
faut qu'il faut trouver les voyous donc
c'est quand même une aide précieuse cela
dit c'est une aide précieuse
mais je considère que c'est quand même
c'est comme l'ordinateur
c'est une aide précieuse mais c'est
quand même les enquêteurs qui commande
qui dirige voyez c'est pas tout et que
par exemple à dans cette affaire moi je
trouve que c'est bientôt ils bientôt les
22 ans de sûreté pour lui son s'est
terminée là donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
est-ce qu'on leur met dehors
moi je dis que les aveux circonstanciés
tels qu'on les a et e oui dit d'ailleurs
si je de façon si je sors je recommence
il le dit on n'a pas forcé si je sors je
recommence et moi je dis que s'il sort
quel que soit l'âge de toute façon ça
n'est pas une question de dire
sexuellement là il va être plus faibles
na nana na na non là dedans c'est
toujours la même mécanique c'est la
pulsion de la jouissance et de tuer il
le dit lui même il explique très bien
donc voilà il faut décider si vous avez
été amené à prendre des décisions
notamment sur le la faire parler de la
ferme madame claude m'aimait mais de
toute façon des prêts des gens qui sont
des deux côtés flics et voyous et
prendre des décisions mais dans ce
métier vous ne faites que ça prendre des
décisions qui aient volé c'est que ça
sur vous que ça repose c'est à dire bon
là on a tous les éléments quand est-ce
qu'on interpelle c'est vous qui donnez
un peu le top de l'interpellation
vous vous êtes le grand coordonnateur si
vous voulez aller alors moi je vous dis
aussi oui sûrement
ce qui m'a donné aussi cette légitimité
je parle de ça parce que la jauge
anticipe que je suis arrivé jusqu'à
directeur du quai des orfèvres et
ensuite même directeur central de la
police judiciaire c'est-à-dire pour
toute la france
le 36 quai des orfèvres c'est paris et
les trois départements de la couronne et
la dcpj
c'est toute la france plus notre mère
etc
donc voyez pourquoi je vous dise ah oui
pour directeur du 36 notamment c'était
caractéristique
j'entendais bien certaine la légine elle
a la légitimité et la légitimité pour
beaucoup c'était parce que j'avais fait
beaucoup de terrain avec eux c'est à
dire je connaissais le métier parker qui
pouvait pas me raconter n'importe quoi
voyez c'est ça aussi c'est ce partage
vous en avait quelques-uns qui sont
arrivés un tout petit peu un peu en
touriste voiliers qui qui était surtout
dans le monde les gens un peu de réseau
pas à pas au sens comme vous aujourd'hui
et vous m'avez comprise donc si oui où
et pas forcément le type qui se défoncer
pour son boulot mais qui savait bien à
guînes naviguer aller faire la leche au
directeur au bon moment et c'est ce que
je n'ai jamais fait jamais et ça n'a pas
empêché voyez-vous de alors vous allez
me dire ah vous avez vu mais c'est
normal c'est une femme dont vous êtes la
libye donc il va falloir n'a pas tant
que ça parce qu'ils en rêvaient je vais
vous dire c'est que je casse la figure
ça ils en ont rêvé
manque de pot je leur ai pas donné
l'occasion parce que j'étais sérieuse
que j'étais rigoureuse que j'avais des
exigences et à la finale j'aurais
tellement pas donné l'occasion c
contient un service qui avait mal
qu'elle est mal pour me demander d'y
aller si on me mettais à la tête pour
redresser le service c'est ça c'est la
légitimité s'il y avait un mot que je
doive choisir si celui ci
et pour conclusion votre vision de
l'évolution gg je me suis permis cette
phrase les voyous reste à huy pas tout à
fait oui alors là vous avez eu raison
parce que alors moi j'ai connu en plus à
travers mon père qui racontait des
histoires comme ses collègues de voyous
moi j'en ai connu quelques-uns 2,3 pas
plus sains aux stups de au banditisme
les vrais des grands voyous viendra ça
vous dira peut-être rien michel ardouin
le porte avions je vous parle de lui
parce que on l'a médiatisé l'a fait un
bouquin là sur les dernières années de
sa vie il parlait lui on s'appelle
porte-avions parce qu'en fait ce gala il
avait un sauna d'armes dans son studio y
avait de la cam
mais il y avait aussi un arsenal d'armes
y compris d'ailleurs y compris et moi je
disais toujours les garçons les plus
jeunes il est peint sa fin ils mettent
les menottes devant les mains devant
surtout pas toujours derrière moi ça
c'est mon père j'avais entendu dire et
c'est donc moi je lui ai fier tu es
toujours çà et là ce jour on arrête
hardoin le porte-avions dans la ceinture
il y avait une dague une courte d'agde
mais il y avait une dague voyez-vous là
mais là vous plantain vie voilà donc
avec les devants en plus on court quand
même plus vite qu'avec les menottes dans
le dos et puis l'idéal c'est de mettre
une note bien pincer à la cheville et là
c'est radical il peut même sortir sans
les menottes de l'immeuble sa 10 ans
orient rien ne se passe sauf qui peut
plus pour rien donc cesser le comprends
mais ça c'est des astuces de vieux
poulets qu'on passe à des jeunes poulets
voix et tout ça pour vous dire ces gars
là bas lui par exemple lui il nous
allons nous a avoué ses crimes mais pas
sur procès verbal
les a jamais eu sur procès verbal mais
il a dit et puis voyez c'est le gars qui
qui qui est kabyle est il dit moi ma
femme elle a un cancer
la cgn qu'une chose à vous demander de
façon je suis fait là je pars au jeu par
au placard pour dix à quinze piges bon
ma bm ars abm c'était une grosse moto
une belle bm qui a est la toute neuve
hilali voilà bon si ma femme pouvait la
récupérer bon on a fait en sorte que sa
femme la récupère voilà lui nous a donné
des informations etc
voyez c'était du voyou on respecte le
poulet on tire pas dessus tout peu de
temps après à la brigade de répression
du banditisme
on tombe sur une équipe il faut un
braquage boulevard soult d'une banque
dès qu'on doit les convoyeurs de fonds
qui livre est bon il le blesse et tire
dans le genou du convoyeur de fonds
l'autre et jeté au sol et ils partent
les vols de voitures vols de vol le vol
de voiture il arrive sur garonor a
toujours poursuivi par les pin pon mais
qu'avait de la distance par rapport à
garonor iliad mercedes qui sort de
grenoble et le type au volant de sa
mercedes
est-ce qu'il était trop gros trop
corpulent n'a pas pu sortir de son
véhicule
ou est ce qu il à résister qui voulait
garder sa mercedes on ne saura jamais
puisqu'ils ont mis une balle dans la
tête
un voyou comme ardouin dans une affaire
comme ça il vous sort le type voyez il
lui faut un coup derrière la tête de
deux révolvers de la crosse et puis le
type il est sonné il prend sa mercedes
il s'en va il l'a pas tué c'est autre
chose c'est il ya du sang froid on tue
pas impunément un poulet on tue pas un
citoyen de voilà on sait quand on fait
des règlements de compte c'est entre
voyous bon voilà ça c'était moi
attention je suis pas en admiration
je dis juste qu'il y avait une forme de
respect c'est tout alors que là la
sphère que je vous dis là de garonor on
a eu à coeur parce que quand vous
frappez à la porte et qui à la mer avec
les deux enfants voilà il faut
l'annoncer celle là pas facile on
s'était juré que le retrouverait cette
bande d'abrutis
on les a retrouvés au bout de neuf mois
9 mois nous a fallu on les a quand même
retrouvé et là ça a été
nique ta mère je crache dessus c'était
un bande de c
je vous épargne de tous les noms
d'oiseaux que nous avons entendu bien
évidemment faut surtout rien dire on ne
fait rien tout se passe bien est ce que
vous avez besoin d'un avocat est ce que
vous prendrez bien une petite collation
et c'est cet envoyé que non mais j'ai
quitté attendre bien qu'il fait attendre
après j'ai été nommé à la direction et
tout ça c'était très bien parce que là
je supportais pas alors que mon rôle est
de dire calmez vous calmez vous surtout
pas un geste malgré toutes les
provocations pas un geste est ce que
vous vous avez une carrière à faire vous
avez des enfants à nourrir que l'ordure
là il faut qu'il aille en taule c'est
tout donc on s'applique c'est le papier
le papier la procédure c'est dur mais on
y arrive pas à l'infini mais en tout cas
merci je me sens très
[Applaudissements]